all right so let's get on over to the
first slide where it says the art and
science of entrepreneurship which is
what we're gonna try to do Chia in about
40 minutes which is the links of two TED
Talks so we better get at it the
approach that we're going to use
everyone is I'm going to more or less do
a play-by-play we're feeding off the
sports analogy because there's a Super
Bowl in the United States on Sunday and
then shortly thereafter
there's the Olympics the Winter Olympics
in Russia so we'll just stay on that
theme and you know this is the year of
the World Cup as well so gyu get to be
the color commentary or advisor analyst
I get to yell gold but you can you can
you can jump in any time we want so
right let's do it
so we are sitting in Silicon Valley and
what is it it's what's this landmass on
this planet around San Francisco and San
Jose but it really in our view is a
state of mind so that the things that
we're going to discuss about the art and
science of entrepreneurship can be seen
through a Silicon Valley lens that's
where we live and it's where we studies
Heuer was a student of mine I'm proud to
say 15 years ago before he started his
distinguished career so here we are you
know using Silicon Valley is a lab but
there are lots of Silicon Valley type
clusters all over the world so we
believe that the things we're going to
talk about over the next half hour are
applicable anywhere on the planet so
let's then let's talk about what do we
mean by entrepreneurship so give you the
one give you the opportunity here to
chime in well I totally agree with you
Tom I think it's it's a state of mind
it's about solving problems that you're
passionate about in a creative and
scrappy way and that really applies
anywhere it's simply a way of thinking
an example I'll give you is our friend
Daniel actors the founder of Spotify he
was sitting in Sweden and he was
incredibly frustrated with the fact that
he could not pay to legally download
music
and so he came up with a product in the
service that enabled people all the
world around to subscribe to an
unlimited library of music and pay a
monthly fee now not everyone is going to
be a Daniel Hecht not everybody is going
to start a company like Spotify but
within your own companies in your
communities in your homes you can apply
entrepreneurial thinking to identify
problems that you're really passionate
about and you solve them in a creative
way well let me build on that and I
don't know how many times they're going
to probably say that in the next
half-hour because you always say
interesting things but let me build on
that by saying look there's a lot of
variations to the word entrepreneurship
and us academics are always trying to
figure out how to you know to
crystallize them so let that we better
do just definitions first these
variations range from the entrepreneur
Daniel as you mentioned or the
Zuckerberg the Mike you know the Michael
Dale did Bill Gates type all the way to
discussion of entrepreneurial ecosystems
or clusters which I've mentioned start
saying hey we've Silicon Valley's a
cluster but frankly it's repeated and
all kinds of other habitats around the
world what we're going to do though in
the interest of time is look at the two
in the middle and that is
entrepreneurship as a process so maybe
you could call that science of
entrepreneurship and entrepreneurial the
adverb or agita Q's me as attitudes and
skills and behaviors in other words to
the art so let's let's do that and bound
it that way so thanks Paul for talking
about the fact that I've got a textbook
in fact today the fourth edition of this
textbook is available that's awesome
yeah just two years of a lot of coffee
and a wonderful co-author and Andrew
Nelson and so we we continually look at
this issue of okay if we're talking
about entrepreneurship and we're talking
about technology entrepreneurship which
is another way of saying high-growth
entrepreneurship scalable business is
not small business but scalable large
businesses like you're trying to with
Spotify what you did was when you invest
in Twitter or before that and your early
investment in Facebook we are trying to
look at what's the principles associated
with that our good friend has a way of
breaking it into two parts opportunity
wrecking the
in pursuit of opportunity up above you
see this collision of products and
markets so we can talk about some
principles having to do with that and
then down below we're in the pursuit of
opportunity we're going to look at some
principles around resources and capital
and people in organizations so we've got
this down to seven principles and that's
a wordy slide very aware of that
these are archived so I won't step
through each one but that's what we're
going to do over the next half an hour
so let's get started first one is simply
put what is why is your venture a a
opportunity not just an idea and I want
to make a couple of comments macro-level
now I'm eternal virtue and from his
vantage point as an investor at a macro
level there are a lot of problems in
this planet to solve and that and it
isn't and it's not going to stop the
entire you can spend a lifetime going at
it to go solve the challenges that we're
facing and digital and physical
infrastructure which a lot of people
think of when they think of
entrepreneurship but frankly it covers
the full spectrum of its sustainability
to security to health and education
obviously I'm trying to solve big
problems in education as a academic
entrepreneur Chiwa tends to invest in
digital infrastructure kind of companies
but is there's a there's a broader
spectrum of big big problems out there
to be saw on the other side the push if
you will there's technologies that are
just fantastic right now and look back
over a couple hundred years back to
railroads which is this university
Stanford was started out of somebody who
did well in railroads to my own career
and software over a wave of decade ago
nor - now we have a wave of just
incredible technologies and we have more
time we could go into that but there's
not only great problems out there to be
solved but there's great technology
taking place so that's the macro level
but Chiwa as an investor I know you
think about those things but what
criteria do you use or will do investors
use when deciding which entrepreneurial
in the back well this is the age-old
debate Tom in in Silicon Valley and in
entrepreneurial centers and investing
centers around the world people ask is
it about market is about the product is
about the team
now I'm gonna split the baby so to speak
unfortunately I'm not going to give you
a single answer but I think it really
depends upon the stage of the company
that we're talking about in a very early
stage company if to entrepreneurs walk
into my office and they say hey I want
to start a company here's an idea
here's a presentation what do you think
I'm looking at the presentation and I'm
looking at the idea but I'm really
looking at those two people mm-hmm what
is the quality of that team what is the
quality of their thinking because more
likely than not 90% of what they have in
that presentation is not going to end up
coming true but it's the approach that
they take because if they're high
quality people and they're experts in
their field they'll navigate their way
to a set of solutions now if it's a
little bit later on and those two people
are team attend and they've got an
initial product and they're coming in
there is asking for investment then the
question that I'd start to ask is what's
the quality of the product have you
really built a better product here and
is it something that can take
significant market share now if it's a
company of a hundred people and they're
coming in and they're looking to raise
20 30 50 million dollars the question
that I have to ask is okay so it seems
like you've got a good team seems like
you've built a good product but
ultimately how large is this market is
this a market that can yield 100 million
dollar business or is it a market that
can yield a two billion dollar business
and ultimately that becomes a
determining factor well very good so now
let's let's dive into some of those
things you just said I mean that this is
essentially a wonderful way to give us
momentum into a few more questions one
of my favorite questions that comes up
in our entrepreneurship courses is
what's your competitive positioning or
elevator pitch and that sounds like a
lot of NBA language there with
positioning so it's but the casual term
is elevator pitch so what's behind all
that it's essentially talking about
strategy and this book that's been
around for over 20 years and
I'm also happy to share because it's
Jeff Moore is a good friend of our
program here big contributor he is
bringing out a new edition of crossing
the chasm this week where it talks about
how how a lot of the entrepreneurs you
just mentioned they may have some early
success they have some a little bit of
momentum but they have trouble getting
to scale they have trouble reaching
escape velocity all those analogies and
that model has been a popular way of
explaining that chasm or that Gulf that
happens in between there were a lot of
startups you know carcasses lie all
right so what is behind that well we use
it as a teaching tool to get at what is
the elevator pitch what's in and it's
common now to call that the story
what is the story of the venture and
that's the description of the product in
the market so how how exciting is it
this is a teaching exercise that we do
where we take a template the two sin is
template where the first sentence
imagine as an engineering professor of
course I imagine this way though that's
the x-axis and that is this how what is
the value to the tutor customer I got
cut off a little bit there but that's
what's going on there the value to the
customer value proposition and the
y-axis and in other words that would be
why should anybody care at all and then
the y-axis is about what why is it that
this particular group of entrepreneurs
of this team the startup why is it
unique that you mean they're solving
somebody's problem but why are they
solving it better than anybody else and
I'm putting an example here of a student
team doing this with what is a fun car
to see driving around at least our area
every once in a while a Tesla ferry an
oculus yeah it's in the it's in the news
and you know there's an example of you
great value push you way out the x-axis
and great uniqueness pushing way up the
y-axis and that's of course what you
want to be is up into the right how does
this jive with the kinds of things you
hear when you hear pitches or elevator
stories yeah so the best pitches are
super simple they can be expressed in a
single sentence and I think they offer
two things they offer a distinctive and
compelling message and the product
offers a disruptive ly better value
propositions and the example uses one
that I'm sure everybody on the the phone
and the the webcast here knows which is
Google so Google has a very distinctive
and compelling message which is find
anything on the internet their search
engine not all their other products but
let's just talk about their search
engine hmm
find anything on the Internet that's a
simple message that any customer or
potential customer of Google can
understand in a single sentence what
they also offered and this goes to your
uniqueness point is they offered a
disruptively better value proposition
when when they launched I remember I was
your student Tom in 1999 and they were
down they did their launch announcement
down in the steps of the gates building
here at Stanford and at the time we had
Yahoo we had meta chrome at a bunch of
these search engines where if you typed
in a search term you could spend a few
minutes paging through the results
clicking through you might end up with a
fourth fifth sixth page to find the
answer that you were looking for and
Google came along and pretty much in 95
or 98 percent of the cases the answer
you were looking for was one of those
first three links and that ended up
becoming a disruptively better value
proposition that enabled them to take
massive market share in a very short
amount of time and create a 200 300
billion dollar company
thanks for that story well it's in an
explanation
let's keep right on rolling let's go to
number three out of seven it was how
much cash do you have it by the way
these are phrased in a way that the
people on the webinar are entrepreneurs
and it just makes it a little bit of a
simulation and because I think all of us
have a little bit of entrepreneur in our
hearts and whether you're you are a
think about standalone venture or
whether you're working in a corporation
right now or a university or in public
service and just you know what you want
to be a change maker so with that in
mind we're just putting it in that
context to make it personal so how much
cash cash do you have my now what are
your major sources Capital all right so
here's what's interesting
entrepreneurs always know how much cash
they
on hand if we were all in a great big
auditorium here together over a football
stadium or something I could pull and
there's entrepreneurs would say yes I
have this many euros or this many yeah
no there's many dollars but this many
might say yes they would do it that way
and but but those of us working in large
enterprises we'd have a hard time we'd
have to google it
hmm me I'll turn around I don't know how
much cash Stanford University has in
this balance sheet right now I just know
I'm gonna get paid and a couple years
more than a few months of - it's right
but anything to watch entrepreneurs
always say oh I've got exit all right so
we got so let's let's let that be but
the the issue is it's usually not enough
to get yet to get the profitability
maybe it might be but it's not enough to
sustaining operations and that given
what they need investment so where's
that come from well I won't tell a quick
story a couple of years ago I was so
honored to teach at the Stanford campus
in Florence and with the book I used for
a course on entrepreneurship was the
textbook plus this book of called Medici
money you people know this some are
probably a little surprised we're
talking about the Medicis but it the
theme in that book was no bankers no
Renaissance that if the Medici had not
been there in the 1400s then
Michelangelo and in DaVinci all these
wonderful things and Ark but especially
in science and technology would not have
happened so that begs the question as I
talked to a venture capitalist is it
really no venture capitalist no Silicon
Valley and we could have a week we could
debate this all day long but let's at
least make the point that it's
worthwhile understanding venture capital
and other source example do you agree
with that all right so let's throw up a
really busy slide but it's important
along the x-axis is here we go with you
know engineering graphs again but
decreasing risk from it shows we're from
the idea stage of a company that's
prints Bramley's and fools all the way
over to profitability which would be the
traditional banks or an initial public
offering and then it shows in the y-axis
the increasing investment size so look
at all those different sources of
capital and my question I want to
talk to you about us what is the major
trends in venture finance today so let's
go back there and see what you think
yeah so I think there's a couple really
powerful mega trends Tom the first is
that it's cheaper than ever to start
companies but more expensive than ever
to scale them so a company can be
started in a dorm room using Amazon Web
Services and using open source software
for like Dropbox data right thousand
bucks five thousand bucks right Y
Combinator's starting these companies
for under $30,000 and that's
extraordinary for the less than the cost
of a luxury sedan you can start a
company let's know Tesla yeah
and get these billions of dollars right
yet at the same time it's more expensive
than ever to scale them you see these
companies raising hundreds of millions
of dollars right some cases billions of
dollars before they go public and the
reason is because the markets are so
enormous in IT you're on the cost of
talent is so high that in order to take
full advantage of the market opportunity
companies have to scale very very
quickly and that's expensive I think a
second mega trend in venture capital is
the shift towards more service intensive
venture capital firms venture capital
used to be very much just a cottage
industry of you know a handful of people
on Sand Hill practicing this business
syndicating their investments with one
another and sharing risk now entire
consulting firms are essentially being
built inside of venture capital firms to
provide to provide services that go top
to bottom including financing services
business development services recruiting
services marketing services and finally
I think at a macro level there is a
significant increases not quite 1999
probably it's healthy that's not but IPO
volume is up significantly in large tech
M&A is back now a multi-billion dollar
tech M&A really insightful and I also
want to do I've see from some input here
from our folks online that we want a
couple of clarification of terms can we
do that DC right in the middle what is
what do we mean by venture capital as
opposed to those others so venture
capital is it's
an asset class in general venture
capitalists get money from institutions
like Stanford University
like Hewlett and Packard Foundation like
the General Motors pension and put it in
the form of a fund that then invests in
individual companies on behalf of those
limited partners speaking to generate a
very high rate of return and what's
unique about venture capital that middle
section there is it's a sizable amount
of investment and at the same time has
extremely high risk assistive here
grandmother lent you a hundred bucks to
start start a lemonade stand it's not a
huge deal if you lost ten hundred
dollars venture capitalists are in the
business of investing 1 to 20 million
sometimes as much as 50 million dollars
in very very high-risk enterprises ok
let's explain a couple of other ones
here F F F is a a bit of humor it is
friends families and fools yes which
I've been one on occasion I best in a
movie once I was I would call that
foolish and then strategic partners
would err what do I mean by that
strategic partners would be a much
larger company that might help your so
corporation pharmaceutical company or if
pharmaceuticals Google yeah ok LSU KITT
yes alright ok good so let's move on to
number four out of seven all right as a
hypothesis-driven lean startup what is
the major risk to reduce ASAP so there's
that phrase lean startup which is
becoming a incredibly important term in
entrepreneurship education lately let's
see what if we can understand it
conventionally the way entrepreneurs and
their teams conversed with people like
Gy and investors and others in the in
the their ecosystems is they did we
talked about look my job is to reduce
risk and I got an identifying the most
important risk for 2014 and we're going
to go after that whether it's kind of
the product or technology work that the
technology risk do we have the right
team as our market big enough or even
you know or can we ever spray
enough capital to get it done because
not everything is inexpensive to do with
software right all right so what
happened is this has been taken and
verified by a number of wonderful
thought leaders saying that look the
business plan isn't so important as the
business model this is how the company
makes money and in a search for that
scalable business model that's much more
important than writing a spiffy business
plan so that's why you see this slide
here so let's let's go on and look at
the contribution made by a fellow in
Europe who wrote a book called business
model generation his name is the
Osterwalder and you see this canvas here
looks a little complicated but it really
is it the top left box is the free there
are the internal operations of the firm
the startup they make a pitch about your
proposition like we talked about earlier
to a set of clients have been customers
and just distribution channels to reach
those customers and ultimately more
revenue needs to come in than costs so
they can live on their own accord and on
investors that mapping and is nice it's
a canvas great but then it's the posting
or a way to test the hypothesis in each
one of those components of the of the
company and this is this created a
movement around something called lean
startup that it even had a cover story
by one of our adjunct professor Steve
Blank it's called why the Lean Startup
changes everything so we teach that we
had spurge people to learn all about it
there's great ways to do that but the
question for you is that's a chip and
test philosophy in other words do a
minimally Viable Product which eternally
use and then get it out right away
like you were describing because it's so
cheap to do that say in software and
then test it even if it's doesn't work
very well is that always better or 'is
more appropriate than this the perfect
and launch so in in the area where I
spend most of my time
yeah the answer is yes and consumer
software it's the kind of business in
the kind of product where you can change
things overnight so you ship a product
it's not working quite right you ship a
bug-fix
Facebook has a legendary example as
where the first few years of the
company's existence maybe even up to
five years or so you know any engineer
could push code live without QA once a
day and they were serving hundreds of
millions of people already because you
know why if it broken during that period
of time there are a lot of things that
broke they just roll it back the next
day and all these would be now if you're
shipping a car if you're testing it's
fairly unlikely that you don't want your
batteries to catch on fire exactly it's
fairly unlikely that you could push a
new build of the car every day so you
much more need to be in the perfect and
launch business and so I think it's it's
dangerous to say ship and test the
philosophy that is appropriate for every
single market in category but what's
that the Fed but what that said talking
to customers and partners and so forth
that that's fine yeah so I think there's
the myth of the entrepreneur which is
the brilliant genius goes into a dark
room with no windows and comes up with
something amazing and it's the next
iPhone that's really not what with a way
entrepreneurship works you need to be in
close touch with the customer you need
to be testing your ideas with the
customer and understanding what their
needs are so that you can satisfy those
needs you might not show them the whole
product but you certainly will you give
them the opportunity or seek feedback on
the features of the product that you're
building all right thanks for that so
let's go to number five which is the
start of our last three five six or
seven having to do with people the tea
some people like to call
entrepreneurship and extreme team sports
since I started this with a the
analogies with the Super Bowl in the
World Cup and the Olympics it is these
guys they look pretty extreme tough yeah
good it's even the ski jumpers have a
team behind them so these are not ski
jumpers this is the the internet
phenomenon known as the picture of
Microsoft from 34 years ago and there's
Bill Gates on the bottom left and with a
nice Koro quote from Margaret Mead but
it really is true isn't it it's these
are teams that you are investing in
they're not just groups of people or a
couple of founders so with that said
though the folks on the call what should
they
do about their own personal skills
because as you'll hear later we had a
lot of fun putting together a course on
this material and I think this stuff can
be learned and so do you so let's talk a
little bit about well what do you mean
stuff what kind of skills can be taught
or you know it should be learned in our
view at Stanford we whether we're coming
from the design crew or the
Entrepreneurship units we like to think
that we're in the business as educators
at creating t-shaped people whether
they're freshmen whether they're
graduate students or whether they're
masters professorship and other
professionals already launched in their
career that means they're really really
good at a particular discipline I was
good at computer science for example but
having a breadth of knowledge in
entrepreneurship innovation leadership
and that's what we think we can we can
teach that as well just like you can
learn a lot about computer science you
can learn that now these are my some of
my favorite skills that we teach with
our thirty-some-odd courses and
entrepreneurship that are sponsored out
of the injury school including to
integrate their strategic thinking
skills up there above like opportunity
evaluation and comfort with change there
are interpersonal skills like persuasion
which is another way of saying selling
and communication what we're doing today
and there's the apprehension teamwork
one and then there's even just you know
basic knowledge of finance and Counting
what do you think about this I think the
most important skill for a entrepreneur
to hone is that of opportunity
evaluation the toughest thing to
identify when you're starting a company
is what's the market opportunity what's
the market need and what product serves
that market need an opportunity
evaluation is that ability to look at a
market such as mobile phones in 2007 and
realize that you need to build something
like the iPhone to completely disrupt
this market which is being poorly served
by an existing solution now along with
opportunity evaluation is comfort with
failure because there are many
many startups that are created to get
one Dropbox or one Eber or one Google or
one Apple and that is a you know it's to
two sides of the same sheet of paper
which is if your great opportunity
evaluation on the other side you're
gonna have a lot of failures in that
process that's a great addition to that
list so let's go to number seven and our
final one sort of because we have a
bonus one we're throwing in since we're
doing so well on time and the seven is
how do you are you making meaning and
scaling your vision that's your venture
this sort of ties back to the first one
which is are there big problems in the
world that needs solving so that this
planet can flourish in this century just
like you know the Renaissance turned
things around in the fourteen hundreds
in Florence so what how is this going to
happen
well it comes it goes down to the
individuals and then individual teams
how are you going to make me and scale
this big purpose I'd we loved this
debate it's it's been going on in
Silicon Valley in a very healthy way for
what ever since HP but especially in the
last twenty years when a professor in a
business school who's now living in
Colorado wrote the first of a series of
books built to last they're on the top
right then good great and great by
choice and then it was amplified by
Sheryl Sandberg's book last year
lean in where she talks about having a
purpose that it isn't about making money
and I remember when you were student or
our entrepreneurship courses in 1999
were they about making money
okay making meaning making me or making
a mean for a purposeful venture so it
sounds trite but it's really truly at
the heart of entrepreneurship do you
have the other toss about that
absolutely you know at our firm we're
just saying called success with
significance that signal on its own is
insufficient but significance is what
really matters and I think it's it's
relevant to look at history if you look
at history there's a lot of people who
made money the people who are remembered
are not those who purely made money or
certainly they're not judged by whether
or not they made money but they're
judged by whether or not
impact and so as you think about the
entrepreneurial opportunities in your
life and around you think about solving
problems that will end up being
impactful if those solutions work it is
uh you know have it having been around a
lot of startups as both an operator and
an investor I can tell you one of the
most interesting dynamics is that it is
harder to solve a small meaningless
problem than to solve a large hairy
important problem because when you're
going after a big hairy important
problem you can attract great people to
help you do it if you're going after a
small meaningless problem you're not
gonna get really great people to help
you with well in fact we used if you
recall we still use Jim Collins's book
and phrase big hairy audacious goals
that came out of the book he had if the
eggs had a built to last so it that's a
universal theme and entrepreneurship
okay so what we've done for the last
half-hour is talk about seven different
ways to learn about entrepreneurship
that's our message this morning that
opportunities are much more than just an
idea the elevator pitch is a great way
of encapsulating strategy you know have
a little fun with the Renaissance of
saying no bankers no Renaissance well at
least let's understand sources of
capital today and the trends and their
pros and advantages and disadvantages of
each that the Lean Startup movement is
significant and it's wonderful to see
that embodiment of a scientific method
that has been around since the
Renaissance the fact that
entrepreneurship is not an individual
thing it is a team sport it's extreme
but it's a team sport ultimately we're
all trying to become better t-shaped
people and there's nothing more
important than making meaning of in
order to achieve scale it's not just
about making money so I'm looking at
Paul seeing if we got a little bit more
time can we do the bonus can we do all
right so all right we are eager to talk
about this because we realize and see
what touch done and earlier there's a
lot of people on this webinar who are
saying well this is fine you know it's
kind of interesting and recreational to
hear about how some of those Silicon
Valley style startups around the world
get underway but what does this have to
do with me as a corporate leader and
manager what does it have to do with it
and I was thinking about another ex
student from the 90s who's worked in a
lot of corporations and I had this
discussion with her
Mariah Finland who's now CEO of a
start-up at nope in your old days she
worked at Motorola and eBay who really
been really big companies and she wrote
down a couple of like uber principles
pick a driver is leader and measure and
fun like a VC so in the interest of time
I won't spend too much time on the top
half but but since I've got you here who
does venture capital I'd love to get
your reactions so these things she says
here give a lot big amounts of money
based on the stage development allow for
growth potential before moving into
metrics mode and then give it two or
three times longer to pay off than you
would think which reaction that yeah I
think that's exactly right Tom it's it's
just like thinking like a VC inside of a
large company because as a operational
leader inside a company you're making
investment decisions there's a great
book called Outsiders which really talks
about named best CEOs in the last
hundred years and those were CEOs they
were all very very different people but
what they held in common was they all
fought like capital allocators inside of
their businesses they made decisions
based upon what's going to be the best
investment for the long term to create
shareholder value
that's essentially what venture
capitalists do we do it with Ross
startups and the people who are on the
phone today do it with raw ideas inside
of their companies and so I think
absolutely building the skill set in the
framework for thinking like a venture
investor inside your company can pay
dividends long-term all right well I
hope that helps stimulate all the folks
on the webinar whether they're
contemplating being part of a small
business it wants to be big or they're a
part of a big business who wants to
innovate again you know and and I hope
everybody found some value out of this I
want to think of another
quote use just a great quote about the
the wind from the firm the success
success with significance also building
on that I have a favorite quote from
Louie pester and this luck favors the
prepared mind mm-hmm so I just urge
everybody to keep getting prepared no
matter what stage of life you're in when
you know whether you're in college now
or whether you are entering some other
part of your life just always prepare
always prepare we've got some you know
slam dunks here layups for you how to
prepare that this particular seminar is
hopefully a gateway to want to learn
more we've got lots of videos and
courses you're going to hear about one
in particular that you and I got to do
which we were just so pleased to be
asked to do those are some of the books
that were mentioned and I like this new
book The Outsiders should add that to it
so with that I'd like to open up to
questions and answers we have a number
of questions here some of which are
highlighted and gentlemen please take it
away get the best questions up and
answer them alright I will read it off
and then we'll take it from there to you
all right first one is does all
entrepreneurship have to be disruptive
does starting a new business and
imitating existing companies also
qualify as entrepreneurship all
entrepreneurship does not have to be
disruptive Tom but it it needs to be
something that you're passionate about
because entrepreneurship is hard there
will be difficult times when you start
your own business or you start your own
venture and because it's hard it's your
passion that's going to carry you
through if you are passionate about
building great cribs handmade baby cribs
or making a great cup of coffee then the
grounds on which to start a new business
or start a new venture
but it's the passion that ultimately is
important if you just want to make some
money
there's a lot easier ways there's money
and starting your own business yeah we
really want problems that's what you do
you start a company yeah and my take on
this is this this word disruption which
is used a good bit and it shouldn't
scare people
way because I think folks immediately
think we're talking about disruption in
technology which is happens we're you
know and but that's usually a big
platform shift to which there's tons of
opportunity to build companies based on
that and we've seen this over and over
from you know going from any computer
supposed to computers personal computers
the internet internet to social
networking just keeps go right on going
so that's Facebook as a platform or you
know that sort of thing but the the flip
side of that coin is disruptions in
business models yeah definitely that's
just as much innovation opportunity
there right and you you you investing
companies were the business model was
disruptive but the technology wasn't in
many cases that's what happens in at a
disruption can just be fundamentally
improving things disruption is not as
complicated as it sounds when you're
disrupting something you're taking away
or you're replacing something that's not
working very well yeah I think of my own
my own experiences I'm trying to just
get to one that I can say quickly well
I'll just put it this way a philosophy
that I've adopted for a while and then
observed that it seems to fit all
situations or situations is that what
your job is an entrepreneurial team is
connect a lot of dots it's in Bob Sutton
in a know a paper long ago when with
Indy hargadon called a knowledge
brokering you just you just take exist
other disruptions and just combine them
into a unique way classic example was
when I was in school here with you Tom
the face book was a piece of paper or a
bundle of paper yeah but if you had slid
under the door of your dorm room the
very first day you got there no mark to
Harvard he thought what we have the web
we have the ability for people to
recognize whether or not they know each
other let's just put this thing online
that's a classic disruption of a poor
product with a much more superior
product that then led to a lot of
opportunities going for it agree yeah so
I'm gonna see how many of you can get
through here I feel like a talk show
host all right Howard this is from Johns
Hopkins hello Jones huh
it's how our social enterprise is
different from classical startups in
terms of the challenge all my goodness I
wish I had the Faculty associated with
our entrepreneurship Center here in the
room and we could we could spend the
rest of the day debating this social
entrepreneurship is really important and
social innovation is really important
yeah guess what there's a number of us
feel that exactly what we were talking
about 45 minutes ago when we said
there's big problems to solve in the
world that is social entrepreneurship
it's just being handled by a for-profit
company yeah now there are nonprofit
entities that go after big problems but
they can use these same principles so
there's the lie it's a little bit of a
false dichotomy that when we're talking
about these kinds of growth enterprises
they can be nonprofits or they be for
profits they just can have a socially
responsible mission yeah and I think
these are businesses and I call them
businesses because they really have the
ability to be worldwide businesses that
are addressing very large market
opportunities with disruptively better
products and the distinction I'd make is
it's just a slightly different business
model so my best friends is a guy named
Scott Harrison yeah we have him speaker
yeah I would say Bar None Scott is one
of the best entrepreneurs in the world
Bar None the market opportunity he's
pursuing is one of the largest ones in
the world bringing clean water to 800
million people that's a pretty large
market opportunity Bar None his product
is disruptively better than what exists
today you can go to charity water you
see the way they use technology and
branding and productizing all of their
services the one thing that's different
is his business model he doesn't sell
anything he is essentially enabling
people to participate in the
implementation of those products out in
the field and that's just slightly
different from the average Silicon
Valley startup that might sell things or
so well I urge people to and thank you
for introducing him to us we in our
seminar that we co-produced with SCPD
every Wednesday afternoon we had him
speak and so there is a it's available
for free like all those up on the web so
if you google Scott Harrison and
his stanford talk yeah you can see him
talking about that to this very tank so
that's that's great if you were building
a company using personal or as we call
them friends families and fool's funds
then let's assume that you're breaking
even even in the first year at what
stage of the company's history do you
need to involve venture capital so
venture capital is a very unique funding
source which is only appropriate if you
want to take on a lot of risk to achieve
a lot of scale if you're starting a
coffee shop and you want to go from one
coffee shops shop to to three or four
coffee shops venture coffee capital is
not appropriate for you you've got a
coffee shop and you want to roll it out
to ten thousand coffee shop in 50
countries yeah that's the point at which
you should bring on Starbucks that's
what he took on I mean in fact he took
on venture capital and it turned out to
be a great venture capital investment
but it came with a lot of risk and the
reason is in that capital side you put
forward yeah venture capitalists in that
center of that that that's charts there
they expect a very very high degree of
return and they're willing to take on a
very very high degree of risk if you
just want to scale a lifestyle business
from one to two stores don't take VC
alright well put let's take a look at
another question really simple one what
are our tips on building a successful
team wow this is a good one I'm
panicking because I got so much to say I
want to come up with some interesting
sound bite because it is so important
and I'll have to just personalize it
what am I trying to do when we're
building out these units for
Entrepreneurship education at Stanford
or for the nation and I'm thinking that
I like unusual people I mean I want to
make sure they're not all the same we
have a way of putting this went even
when we're selecting students in that
program you were in it's like outfitting
a living room
and you don't want all couches you know
every you want coffee table and chairs
and rugs and paintings and so forth so
and sometimes if maybe you want a
Picasso you know really on creative an
unusual one so I think that's one the
other and putting together a team is
transparency and communication I mean as
the leader share everything yep because
in this world yeah yeah and in this
world that we live in of digital you
know just digital communications to the
max and informations everywhere any
other way of bleeding we're managing is
not going to build a lot of teamwork I
agree I agree and your friend Jim
Collins he has a couple good principals
and I'm not gonna quote him perfectly
here but in principle what he says is
one make sure that you have a players at
everything we'll see it around the table
right not ever ever accept mediocrity on
your team they may be your best friend
but if they're not the best person to do
that job you need to be intellectually
honest with yourself and secondly make
sure you have the right people in the
right seat a lot of times you have great
people that might not be doing the best
job because not because you're not great
but because they're not in the right
role yeah thanks for bringing that up I
think that's terrific okay so let's look
at numbers the next one there if yeah if
a VC sees a great team with a compelling
idea but that team has tried a previous
venture and failed does the VC regard
that as a negative I mean I put it in
she was just she won't want to hear what
happened in the previous venture I think
it's a good way to finish off yet this
is fantastic because I think this is
what makes Silicon Valley so unique and
you talk to the beginning time about
Silicon Valley being a state of mind
I think Silicon Valley may be the only
place in the world where failure is
viewed as a badge of honor
I failed you failed we've all been
involved in companies advising or
investing in companies that have failed
and the reason that failure is so
important is because you learn just as
much from failure if not more than from
success well I'm telling you though Qi
what and this is what's so exciting
about the last 10 years I've been able
to teach this material in Abu Dhabi
Santiago Helsinki Taiwan Singapore Bay
New York and this issue comes up so this
generation of people thanks to the
Internet you know the flat world support
is not going to accept the old way where
failure was somehow failure they see it
as data collection they see it as the
scientific method so I fact I think this
notion this principle might have been
rarified at Silicon Valley but is
spreading and it gives me great hope and
optimism all right so with that I'll
turn back to Paul to tiwa Tom thank you
so much there are many many more
dimensions that we could cover but
unfortunately are limited to time and we
do try to keep the timeframe I just want
to remind you for those who are not
familiar the Stanford innovation
entrepreneurship certificate consists of
of a number of courses from which you
select core and elective offerings to
complete the certificate and we've had a
number of people run through that so
we're very pleased with the early early
outcomes there I do want to make mention
that we do appreciate our faculty
spending time to join us we will be
answering a few of the additional
questions online so if you're still
online please hang in there we might be
able to get to those questions and do
join us in future webinars as your time
permits we do archive everything on our
channel so you'll be able to access that
as well and with that I want to again
thank our speakers Professor Tom Byers a
cheap watch in and we want to wish you a
very good day wherever you are in the
world thank you
you